[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Marc Nobel bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes historien et essiste
merci d'avoir accepter notre invitation
karinazopard dit bonjour merci d'être là
vous êtes journaliste auteur de ces deux
livres qu'on va voir ces petits
renoncements qui tuent et quand la peur
gouverne tout on va évidemment parler de
tout ça merci également d'être avec nous
et à distance en visio avec nous
Jean-Pierre sacoune bonjour merci
également d'être avec nous vous êtes
président de l'association unité laïque
on va parler avec vous notamment de la
montée des actes antisémites de
l'inquiétude de la communauté juive mais
également de l'inquiétude des
enseignants sur le respect de la laïcité
à l'école y a-t-il une importation du
conflit du Proche Orient ou le problème
est-il beaucoup plus profond on va
évidemment parler de tous ces sujets
Mathias hier les sénateurs ont beaucoup
interrogé le gouvernement sur ces
questions notamment sur les leçons à
tirées de l'attaque d'aras absolument on
en parlera avec vous évidemment dans
quelques instants c'est parti pour ce
[Musique]
club et avant de vous entendre on va
regarder notre reportage en France la
communauté juive s'inquiète des
conséquences du conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas depuis le 7 octobre le nombre
d'actes antisémites à fortement augmenté
dans notre pays on regarde ce reportage
de Samia de chien dans la nuit du 22 ou
23 juillet 2015 l'appartement d'Alain
est cambriolé pour la deuxième fois en 2
mois une histoire qu'il n'ose toujours
pas raconter à visage d'couvert nous
étions certainement repérés et fichés
par des gens extérieurs ou qui habitaent
dans l'immeuble ces gens ont donc forcé
laappte de notre appartement dans la
chambre de nos enfants ils ont inscrit
sur les murs au feutrre pas au feutre
mais à au rouge à lèvres que ma femme
avait laissé sur une étagère sal juif
vive la
Palestine donc nous avons compris
qu'après ce deuxième cambriolage qui
était un cambriage ciblé et
antisémite nous n'avions plus notre
place malheureusement dans la commune de
Bondi ils vivent désormais à Villemomble
une autre ville de scène Saint-Denis
qu'il juge moins exposé à
l'antisémitisme mais il continue de
craindre les conséquences du conflit en
cours entre Israël et le Hamas lors des
différentes guerre qui a eu entre Israël
et la bande de Gaza ou quand il a eu des
antifad à chaque fois le conflit est
exporté en France avec toutes les
craintes que l'on peut avoir et donc
j'ai les plus grandes craintes
effectivement qui a une
recréescence à la fois des tags mais
également des attaques physiques une
crainte par les représentants de la
communauté juive en France depuis
l'attaque terroriste lancée par le Hamas
sur Israël le 7 octobre le nombre d'acte
antisémite a fortement augmenté dans
l'Hexagone d'abord ce qui est quand même
effarant c'est 20 actes antisémites par
jour c'est-à-dire quasiment un par heure
c'est vertigineux et pour le
moment la crainte qu'on peut avoir c'est
que ces actes prennent une autre
dimension une dimension beaucoup plus
grave
et on espère que ce ne sera évidemment
jamais le cas dans les universités le
climat est particulièrement tendu Jérémy
Cohen Solal est membre de l'Union des
étudiants Ju de France il vient de
participer à une action de collage
condamnant l'attaque du has on été collé
la Dauphine j'ai pas eu remonter encore
il quoi d'autre encore Odéon elles ont
été arraché directement depuis l'attaque
du 7 octobre Jérémie d redoublé de
vigilance par exemple le seul endroit à
côté de ma fac pour mes pausees déjeuner
en fait où je peux manger ccher
normalement c'est c'est le hypercacher à
côté de ma fac qui est a 10 minutes mais
maintenant avec les événements récents
j'évite d'y aller et je je fais plutôt
des j'essaie d'avoir plutôt des
commandes à récupérer et me poser dans
des endroits où je connais bien où j'ai
des amis où je me sens en sécurité
d'après un sondage mené en septembre
avant les affrontements entre Israël et
le has plus de 9 étudiants juifs sur 10
disaient déjà avoir été confrontés à
l'antisémitisme Marc Nobel on voit ces
témoignages qui sont évidemment
poignants est-ce que l'inquiétude de la
communauté juive de France est très vive
aujourd'hui l'inquiétude de la
communauté juive est très vive depuis
l'année 2000 en réalité pas seulement
depuis aujourd'hui quoi qu'aujourd'hui
nous remarquons puisque nous disposons
d'indicateurs qui ont été donnés par le
ministre de l'Intérieur que 327
antisémite ont été comptabilisés depuis
12 jours c'est considérable c'est
considérable pour vous donner un ordre
de comparaison 436 actes avaient été
comptabilisés pour l'ensemble de l'année
2022 et donc il est tout à fait normal
dans ces circonstances que les Juifs de
France soient inquiets ils le sont et
bien évidemment je le comprends donc il
y a une flambée depuis le début depuis
l'attaque du has il y a une FL on peut
parler de flambé il y a bien sûr il y a
une flambé d'antisémitisteme
comme je je je vous l'ai indiquer en
réalité depuis 2000 d'ailleurs voici un
graphique qui va vous le montrer ce
graphique comptabilise les actes
antisémites depuis 2000
1391 actes antisémites ont été
comptabilisés de 2000 à 2022 dans les
pics les haut que vous voyez oui voilà
expliquez-nous parce qu'on on voit pas
bien à quoi correspond parce que il y a
beaucoup d'oscillations voilà il y a des
bas des bas au niveau des chiffres des
actes et des haut lorsque nous sommes
dans les et haut vous voyez 2000 2002
2004 2009 2014 2017 par exemple pour ne
citer que ces années-là nous sommes en
plein dans un conflit entre Israël et le
ramas ou Israël et les Palestiniens et
ses répercussions sur le territoire
national pour vous donner un autre
chiffre pour qu'on comprenne bien ce
dont on parle en 1999
89 actes avaient été comptabilisé nous
passons à 744 en 2000 et encore
s'agit-il de la période du 1er octobre à
la fin de l'année 2000 et tout cela en
rapport avec le conflit
israëlo-palestinien donc ça montre qu'il
y a clairement une importation de ce
conflit il y a une importation des
passions et des folies autour de ce
conflit mais d'un seul d'un seul côté
les Juifs ne ne vont pas agresser des
gens eux il y a eu une manifestation il
y a quelques jours elle était
relativement calme on peut être contre
on peut être pour mais elle était calme
ce qui n'a pas été le cas de toutes les
manifestations propalestin
en 2014 en juillet 2014 lorsqu'elles ont
eu lieu karinazopardi je vous ai V
réagir sur ma question oui parce que
c'est pas seulement une importation du
conflit d'après moi le le le la
signification de ce qui est en train de
se passer est plus large et ce ne se ne
se déroule pas seulement en France on
voit les mêmes phénomènes se produire
jusqu'en Australie où il y a eu quand
même une manifestation au cri de gazer
les juif on est en 2023 on ne pensait
jamais réentendre ce genre de parole et
sous l'œil plutôt complaisant de la
police australienne qui n'a pas fait
cesser cette manifestation qui a duré de
de longues minutes et donc pour moi
l'antisémitisme qui se déroule est un
pur antisémitisme dans nos pays
européens et américains d'ailleurs les
chiffres sont très clairs vous les avez
rappelé et ils sont les mêmes pour
l'ensemble de l'Europe ils sont très
préoccupants et pour les États-Unis ce
qui est une nouveauté et c'est un
antisémitisme qui est directement lié à
mon sens à la montée de l'Islam de de
l'islam politique de l'islamisme dans
nos pays avec l'importation pour le coup
d'une version rigorisque de l'islam qui
est montée depuis 20 30 ans au
Moyen-Orient et au Proche-Orient et en
Afrique du Nord et qui a traversé la
Méditerranée vous parlez des pays
européens et américains ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas une particularité de la
France qui qui évidemment il y a une
communauté juif très importante en
France mais vous dites c'est le problème
n'est pas qu'en France non en Allemagne
c'est exactement la même chose on l'a vu
en Angleterre c'est pareil il y a eu des
manifestation monstre jusqu'en Irlande
il y a eu des des des soucis et aux
États-Unis il y a eu des agressions
antisémites même qui n'était pas lié au
dernier au dernier conflit en cours qui
qui ont eu lieu l'année dernière Marc
Nobel c'est pas un problème qui est
spécifique à la France nous avons
peut-être devancer d'autres pays puisque
les actes ici comptabilisé tel que je
vous en ai t que je vous l'ai cité tout
à l'heure tout cela arrive en 2000 dès
octobre 2000 peut-être bien avant
d'autres pays mais en effet vous avez
raison cette cette flambée d'acte
antisémite prend dans différents pays et
en effet vous avez raison il il faut
pointer du doigt l'islamisme là-dessus
un seul exemple si vous me permettez oui
après je vous demande juste une petite
une petite précision qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière les actes antisémites
concrètement alors ce que l'on appelle
actes antisémite ce sont deux choses ce
sont à la fois des menaces qui sont
adressés sur internet par courrier
oralement et ainsi de suite les menaces
que l'on a vu à l'écran là tout à
l'heure avec votre reportage mais ce
sont également des actions violentes
c'est-à-dire des coups perpétrés
perpétré contre des individus à la
sortie de synagogue par exemple des
lancé de cocktail molotophe contre des
synagogues des tentatives d'incendie des
profanations des choses extrêmement
violentes et puisque vous avez parlé de
l'islamisme en effet il faut le dire je
ne citerai ici qu'un seul exemple en
2012 je ne veux pas citer son nom
lorsqu'un terroriste est entré à
l'intérieur de l'enceinte de l'enceinte
auaratora du de l'établissement scolaire
confessionnel auaratora à tout louse il
a massacré trois enfants une enfant de 4
ans un enfant de 5 ans un enfant de 7
ans et le père de deux d'entre eux et il
l'a fait nous disait-il prétextait-il au
nom de la violence qui serait qui est
perpétrée contre les enfants
palestiniens il il n'y a aucun parallèle
à faire mais dans sa folie cet homme a
argué de cela et ce que je veux dire
c'est que une enfant de 4 ans a été
pointé du pistolet sur sa tête elle est
morte dans un établissement scolaire à
Toulouse c'est vous dire la folie de ses
gens en réalité vous vous rappelez
justement Marc Nobel cette tuie il y a
eu malheureusement d'autres événement il
y a eu Sarah limi il y a eu Ilana liimi
il y a eu également l'hyper cacher la
communauté juive de France a des
traumatismes ils sont ravivés par ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui la communauté juive
de France n'en peut plus autant le dire
vous savez il faut utiliser les mots
qu'il faut ce ce n'est pas une vie que
de dépendre comme ça du bon vouloir d'un
certain nombre de gens furieux et
déchaînés ce que la communauté juive ce
dont elle a besoin c'est de sécurité et
de respect et pas seulement d'ailleurs
la communauté juive parce que en fait
nos compatriotes sont inquiets ils ont
raison de l'être nous avons vu ce qu'il
en a été de l'assassinat de de cet
enseignant à haras et je crains fort de
ce qu'il pourrait arriver les jours
prochains et ça c'est absolument
intolérable intolérable c'està-dire sur
ce qui pourrait arriver vous pensez que
ça peut mon encore si c'est possible
vous voyeze encore avoir une Escal nous
avons une attaque à Bruxelles et de deux
personnes ont été assassinées nous avons
eu cette attaque à haras un professeur a
été assassiné deux autres trois autres
ont été blessés et une multiplication
plus les menaces plus les menaces et
tout ça augur mal de ce qui pourrait se
passer les jours prochains Jean-Pierre
sacoun je vous fais réagir à à tout ce
qu'on est en train de dire sur sur le
plateau et notamment sur l'inquiétude
exprimée par Marc Nobel à
l'instant
oui bonjour j'interviendrai en tant que
laïque et pas en tant que
spécialiste de la de du du conflit en
cours je voudrais simplement dire une
chose faites attention à l'usage
permanent du mot communauté les Français
juifs font partie de la communauté
nationale les représentés toujours sous
le nom de la communauté juive c'est
installé l'idée qu'ils sont à part et
c'est installé l'idée que nous sommes
dans une situation dans laquelle on se
trouve communauté face sa communauté non
ce sont des Français de confession de
culture d'origine juive et ces Français
sont touchés comme tous les autres
Français plus que tous les autres
Français et il ne faut pas les séparer
il faut au contraire les réintégrer dans
la communauté nationale dans tous nos
discours dans toutes nos paroles pour
rappeler à tous nos concitoyens que
c'est nous tous qui sommes touchés et
pas simplement les Juifs et vous faitz
bien de le rappeler effectivement
Jean-Pierre sacoun Karina azopard oui
c'est ce que
c'est une expression que j'emploie c'est
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui par
rapport au Juifs c'est le canari dans la
mine ça doit nous alerter c'est-à-dire
que la doctrine anti la doctrine
islamiste a en son cœur la doctrine
enfin l'antisémitisme est au cœur de sa
doctrine quand on voit la manière dont
les Protocoles des Sages de Sion sont
développés dans l'ensemble ENF peut-être
pas l'ensemble mais dans de nombreux
pays arabes où ça a été décliné en donc
c'est ce ce ce livre complotiste he que
Hitler avait sur sa table de de de
chevet c'est aujourd'hui une série dans
qui a été tournée en Égypte et diffusée
dans de nombreux pays arabes et donc
l'antisémitisme est consubstantiel à la
monté de cet islam rigoriste dure et
c'est en cela que l'antisémitisme c'est
un Canarie d' la mine qui nous concerne
absolument tous ce n'est pas juste une
histoire de communauté un un un mot
quand même là-dessus parce qu'on a vu
dans le reportage de Samia dechir le
témoignage de ce couple qui avait dû
déménager puisqu'il avait été camb
briolé chez lui victime d'acte
antisémite mais il est resté en France
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
Français juifs de Juifs de France qui
quittent la France parce qu'ils ont peur
alors je puis vous donner un chiffre qui
est un chiffre officiel c'est celui de
l'agence juif pour Israël
68457 Français de confession juives ont
fait leur allas en Israël depuis 2000
une bonne moitié de ceux sont partis
parce qu'ils avaient peur ceux qui ne
sont pas partis en Israël lorsqu'ils
vivent dans des B lieu difficile où
s'ils se sentent menacés tentent de
déménager s'ils en ont les moyens s'ils
ont une opportunité pour aller d'un
endroit à un autre d'une ville à une
autre pour essayer de ne plus être
menacé comme ils le sont un un un
dernier indicateur les les enfants juifs
qui étaient dans les écoles
républicaines ont commencé à quitter
l'école républicaine des 2004 parce que
leurs parents se sont inquiétés de
l'antis sitisme montant dans certains
établissements scolaires et donc ils ont
placé leurs les leurs enfants et donc
ses élèves dans des écoles
confessionnelles ce qui en réalité est
terrible enfin tout c est terrible
justement on va parler de ces questions
de l'école et de l'inquiétude évidemment
à l'école dans le milieu enseignant et
dub et de la laïcité à l'école Mathias
il a été beaucoup questions de ces
sujets hier au Sénat lors de la séance
de question d'actualité au Gouvernement
moins d'une semaine après l'assassinat
de Dominique Bernard les parlementaires
de tout B ont questionné les ministres
concernés la première d'entre eux
ellisabeth borne le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel hatal ou
encore celui de l'Intérieur Gérald
armanin sur les répercussions les causes
les réponses à apportter à cette menace
de voir d'autres attentats survenir sur
le territoire le locataire de beauovau a
expliqué que malgré le contexte au Sahel
ou au Moyen-Orient la principale
inquiétude des services de renseignement
ne provient pas de l'extérieur de nos
frontières ce principe vous le savez
c'est une menace endogène une
ubérisation pardon de ce mot du
terrorisme qui attend la publication des
caricatures des soi-disant blasphèmes
des soi-disant difficultés qui toucherai
le monde particulier pour lequel ils
seraient attachés dans leur
fantasmogorie des complots sur Internet
qui peut-être permet de passer à l'acte
Géral a également souligné son bilan à
l'intérieur depuis 5 ans pour signif à
quel point la menace terroriste est
importante en France on parle Orian de
43 attentats déjoués soit un tous les
toutes les 6 semaines 1500 personnes
interpellées qui ont un lien direct avec
l'apologie du terrorisme et 6500
personnes par an sous technique de
renseignement est-ce que c'est réponse
ont convaincu les sénateurs et bien pas
tous vous le savez certains font un lien
clair entre terrorisme et immigration le
cas ici d'aras en est l'illustration
l'assassin de Dominique Bernard était en
situation irrégulière mais é protégé par
le Droit un droit que certains
aimeraient voir changer
rapidement monsieur le ministre il ne
faut pas se limiter à la surveillance il
faut agir contre les ennemis de la
République à ceux qui n'aiment pas la
France qu'ils partent nous ne les
retenons pas et surtout nous ne devons
pas les attirer ni en France ni en
Europe car moi la France je
l'aime un petit un petit coup de main de
Jean-François rappin sénateur LR du Pas
de Calais au ministre de l'Intérieur qui
comme vous le savez défendra sa loi
immigration au Sénat à partir du 6
novembre prochain un Gérald d'armanin
qui n'a pas hésité à rendre à son tour
hommage aux membres de la commission des
Lois du Sénat en leur disant mot pour
mot vos modifications du texte je l'ai
fait mienne et au-delà de la menaceorist
les sénateurs se sont inquiétés du
climat que la situation peut faire
régner dans certains établissements
scolaires oui Gabriel Attal est
notamment revenu sur les plus de 350
incidents recensé dans les écoles lors
de la minute de silence en hommage à
l'enseignant et je continuerai à avoir
une très grande fermeté sur le sujet en
rappelant deux règles élémentaires le
souvenir de professeurs qui sont tombés
pour l'école on ne le piétine pas on
l'honore et l'autorité de l'école et de
la République on ne la conteste pas on
s'y soumet le ministre a par ailleurs
précisé que des saisin du procureur de
la République ont été faites pour chacun
des cas pour engager des poursuites
contre les élèves et que dans les cas
les plus graves qui relèvent de
l'apologie du terrorisme des exclusions
immédiates ont été ordonnées en
attendant des procédures disciplinaires
voilà on rappelle ce chiffre au moins
357 perturbations contestation pendant
la minute d'hommage à Dominique Bernard
lundi qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir derrière
ces chiffr Marc Nobel une montée de la
radicalisation une folie furieuse
l'instrumentalisation
d'islamiste le doute chez les
enseignants la peur même chez les
enseignants ils sont ils sont lâchés ce
n'est pas facile je suis un ancien
professeur d'histoire donc je peux le
comprendre je peux comprendre ce
désarroir mais le ministre a raison il
faut être pour ces questions extrêmement
ferme et ne pas tolérer ce désordre euh
le désordre auquel nous assistons dans
les école et qui peut conduire à cette
folie euh celle auquelle nous ce à quoi
nous avons assisté il y a quelques jour
l'assassinat d'un professeur et l'on a
dit et je veux bien le croire que
l'agresseur l'assassin disait ne pas
aimer la France qu'il l'a détestait il a
choisi un professeur au hasard
choisissant de le tuer sans raison
aucune et cherchant par là même aussi à
tuer un professeur d'histoire c'est tout
dire en vérité ouais justement est-ce
que c'est aussi tout dire sur les
failles peut-être de l'école publique
c'est effectivement un ancien élève qui
a été éduqué en France qui est arrivé en
France très jeune qui a fait tout ce que
sa scolarité dans notre pays et qui a
tué un professeur est-ce que ça réveille
les failles de l'école publique qui l'a
éduqué je sais pas si on peut tout
mettre sur le dos de l'école publique et
des professeurs parce que c'est un
problème plus large que que ça qu' les
ils ont ils en ont beaucoup sur sur
leurs épaules après le conflit
palestinien pour revenir dessus est vu
comme une métonymie par beaucoup
d'élèves c'est-à-dire que à force de
victimisation de certains entrepreneurs
à l'extérieur de l'école et puis aussi
d'une certaine frange de
militants que j'appelle le Wook mais
c'est un peu trop loin à expliquer on il
y a une identification qui est faite à à
ces musulmans soi-disant
voilà persécuté
assiégé dans les territoires
occupés en en Israël et donc il y a une
identification très forte qui est faite
ici par ces élèves qui qui ne
comprennent pas toujours la laïcité et
qui ne comprennent pas et qui contestent
les enseignements c'est ce qu'on avait
d'ailleurs montré dans notre premier
livre beaucoup d'enseignements sont
contestés mais c'est pas juste la Choa
ou des enseignements d'histoire c'est
juste non monsieur la terre
né par onde elle est plate on ESS mais
est-ce que ça renforce un peu plus le
choc pour un enseignant de savoir que
c'est un ancien élève qui a commis cet
acte les alors moi les enseignants avec
qui j'ai parlé depuis la semaine
dernière puisquon a été évidemment très
touché par ce qui s'est passé encore
vendredi lundi c'était la commémoration
des 3 ans de l'assassinat de Samuel pati
vous imaginez que l'émotion était était
grande les professeurs qui sont que je
connais qui sont retournés à l'école
lundi matin je peux vous le dire l'ont
fait la peur au ventre encore plus que
d'habitude mais il le font trop souvent
euh voilà alors c'est pas partout c'est
pas dans toutes les classes évidemment
il faut raison garder mais certains
professeurs qui vont enseigner dans
certains lycées et dans certains
quartiers le son allé lundi matin la
peur au ventre parce que comme le disait
mon Couteur du premier livre Samuel
Patis aurait pu être moi ça peut être
n'importequel d'entre eux et ils ont ce
sentiment chevillé au corps Jean-Pierre
sacoun làdessus sur sur cette question
de la laïcité à
l'école c'est une question sont
tellement profondes qu'il faudrait une
émission de plusieurs heures pour
commencer à approcher de la réalité ce
ce dont on se rend compte c'est que la
laïcité qui est un projet politique qui
est le projet le plus profond que la
France est mise en place depuis le 16e
siècle depuis les guerres de religion
qui ont marqué ce pays dans l'histoire
dans la durée dans la longue durée de
l'histoire pour des siècles que cette
laïcité est la manière dont nous avons
construit une société politique qui
permet à tous les êtres humains qui VI
sur notre territoire d'être français du
jour où ils arrivent sur ce territoire à
une condition d'accepter une règle la
séparation des Églises et de l'État et
d'accepter une autre règle la liberté de
conscience et la volonté d'émancipation
à chacun ensuite de choisir et donc
l'école est le lieu de cette
émancipation de cette proposition
d'émancipation et donc à ce titre
l'école est effectivement un sanctuaire
un sanctuaire qui doit comme le disait
Jan dans ses circulaires des années 36
38 un sanctuaire qui doit être protégé
de toutes les scorie de la société et en
particulier des habitudes familiales et
cette laïcité elle ne s'apprend pas
comme une matière c'est un peu comme
l'absurdité des cours de culture
générale la culture générale ça
s'apprend pas ça se construit et la
laïcité de la même façon ça se construit
ça se construit par l'instruction
publique c'est-à-dire la institution
progressive de savoir QUI élève l'enfant
d'où son nom d'élève qui l'institue d'où
le fameux nom des instituteurs que je
préfère tellement à celui de professeur
des écoles et qui lui permett de devenir
un citoyen parce que nous vivons en plus
dans un pays dans lequel nous avons fait
un Paris extraordinaire c'est de pouvoir
construire une société sans avoir une
morale qui nous surplombe qui vienne de
la religion à la différ des lumières
anglaises qui nous disaient il faut
qu'il y ait une morale religieuse pour
que les citoyens puissent être des
citoyens nous nous disons construisons
ensemble cette morale et c'est l'école
qui le fait pas à travers des cours de
laïcité mais à travers l'instruction
publique et l'éducation il faudrait nous
tourner vers les parents et leur
rappeler que c'est eux qui en sont
responsables et pas l'école et autre
chose une dernière chose avant de
excusez-moi de vous rendre la parole euh
il faut aussi que le pas de vaguisme
comme on dit avec de de cette nouvelle
expression soit
éradiqué des structures et des échanges
intermédiaires de responsabilité de
l'école si on en a le temps je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé hier au
lycée maricury
àut je je vous redonne la parole mais
vous avez dit deux choses très
importantes sur lesquel on va revenir
d'abord l'école Marc Nobel c'est un
objectif stratégique pour les islamistes
parce que l'école est là aussi pour
contrecarrer justement l'idéologie qui
tente d'inculquer l'idéologie islamiste
dans une revue de
d'alqaïda vous trouviez toutes les
menaces possibles contre les les écoles
et notre système éducatif car pour eux
cela constitue un danger voilà donc ils
ont passé leur temps en tout cas dans le
numéro que j'avais consulté à menacé
l'école française et les enseignants et
à vouloir détruire cette école en tant
que telle il faut donc résister ne pas
céder les valeurs que nous défendons
sont des valeurs essentielles celles de
la laïcité mais c'est au-delà la
République que nous aimons et on ne
serait transiger et et et et accepter
d'être menacé en tant que tel bien sûr
il dépend du pouvoir politique de
prendre les mesures nécessaires et de la
société de considérer les menaces en
tant que telles et de bien les analyser
et justement ne pas céder c'est la
deuxième chose dont vous avez parlé
Jean-Pierre Sakou Karine azopardi le pas
de vaguisme pour reprendre l'impression
l'expression de Jean-Pierre Sakou est-ce
que finalement ce sont ces petits
renoncements qui produisent le
grand oui sans doute après est-ce
que là il y a quand même eu des paroles
très claires du ministre depuis depuis
juillet août on a vu avec Samuel pti qu'
avait pas été soutenu par l'institution
VO par oui oui on a perdu un an et ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que ce qui
est visé à travers l'école et vous le
rappeliez très justement dans les dans
les communications d'Al-Qaïda et puis
dans plus largement euh dans les les
publications de l'islam politique qu'on
peut qu'on peut observer c'est que
l'école est visée parce qu'elle est le
symbole de l'état d'une part et d'autre
part parce qu'elle est le lieu
d'émancipation où on apprend aux élèves
un esprit critique et c'est un esprit
critique qui va frontalement euh contre
le le le le dogme et les les croyances
euh à l'école on opère une déliaison
entre l'extérieur et le sanctuaire que
doit être l'école et le savoir et le
savoir et parfois en concurrence directe
avec le la les croyances et quand on a
des parents d'élèves ou des élèves qui
disent monsieur ma religion est
au-dessus de votre République ça veut
tout dire et donc évidemment que la
fermeté euh c'est un
minimum juste je voulais faire réagir
Caren zobardi et Marc Noel je vous
redonne la parole Jean-Pierre sacoun
pour n nous raconter rapidement ce qui
s'est passé à saut ce dont vous nous
parliez ce qui s'est passé à saut le il
y avait une exposition sur l'histoire du
lycée marieury pendant la 2uxème Guerre
mondiale qui faisait apparaître
l'héroïsme d'un certain nombre
d'enseignants dont une enseignante juive
et bien le proviseur a décidé de retirer
cette exposition des grilles du lycée de
peur que cette exposition n'excite
l'esprit malade des antisémites
islamistes qui voudrait s'attaquer ainsi
au lycée donc nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une situation dans laquelle le
simple fait de mentionner
l'existence et l'action de Français
juifs même si c'est une action héroïque
entraîne censure de la part de et on
doit l'appeler censure de la part des
échelons intermédiaire de direction de
l'éducation nationale et d'une certaine
manière je comprends le proviseur parce
que s'il ne le fait pas et qu'il y a un
incident il il se trouvera toujours dans
la hiérarchie un inspecteur pour le lui
reprocher et mal le noté et le ministre
et avant lui Jean-Michel
Blanquer ne pensons plus à la triste
période intermédiaire entre ces deux
ministres prend aujourd'hui des
décisions les affirme mais son travail
sera de faire passer dans un ministère
qui en 40 ans est pass de la défense de
la laïcité et de l'affirmation de la
laïcité à une forme de communautarisme
rampant je le dis de faire passer ces
idées ça a mis 40 ans pour aller dans un
sens il faudra probablement une
génération pour y arriver mais là pour
le coup comme le disait tout à l'heure
le général dans votre émission
précédente la continuité de l'État doit
absolument s'affirmer pour que cet
effort soit constant vers un retour de
la laïcité à tous les échelons du
ministère
et il y a eu trop d'auciliation
politiques ces dernières années
là-dessus pour que la lutte soit
efficace Karina zopardu et bien surtout
les je pense que les
personnel de l'éducation nationale était
en attente d'une ligne claire euh juste
une anecdote il y a eu dans un lycée
improviseur ou un proviseur adjoint je
ne me souviens plus qui l'an dernier
laissait passer les abayas et cetera à
partir du moment où il y a eu une ligne
claire du ministère début septembre il a
pu rien laisser passer il avait besoin
d'être soutenu et la hiérarchie a besoin
d'être soutenu et les profs ont besoin
d'être soutenu par leur hiérarchie il
faut qu'il y ait une Lig une ligne
claire c'est ce qui me semble on va sur
C dans cette direction c'est le minimum
ouais un dernier mot Marc Nobel on va
vers une ligne claire et est-ce que pour
mener cette bataille il faut une unité
nationale sur le sujet est-ce qu'elle
est possible aujourd'hui j'avais publié
en 2001 dans Libération un article que
voici trop de silence face à la flambée
antisémite et dans le chapeau j'avais
écrit
les pouvoirs publics font preuve de
molesse devant les agressions antijuives
qui se multiplient depuis un an
c'est-à-dire depuis 2000 octobre 2000
novembre 2001 tout renoncement c'est
abandonner les valeurs de la République
c'est excusez-moi l'expression mais
baisser la culotte en fait c'est
inacceptable nous gagnerons il faut
gagner nous gagnerons pour défendre
notre République et les valeurs de la
République et cela passe par une
certaine
fermeté merci merci à tous d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau pour parler
évidemment de ce sujet essentiel si vous
voulez bien rester avec nous quelques
instants on va regarder ce qu' a la une
de la presse
[Musique]
régionale et Mathias c'est la frappe
meurtrière sur un hôpital de Gaza et ces
conséquences qui sont à la une de
plusieurs de nos quotidiens régionaux le
tir qui indigne et change la donne
s'interroge le Dauphiné Libéré 2 jours
après l'attaque qui pourrait avoir coûté
la vie à plusieurs centaines de Gazaoui
différents journaux soulèvent les
questions et retiennent la colère
provoquée par cet événement c'est le cas
des hou là des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace qui évoque un possible tournant
dans la guerre car comme on peut le voir
à la une du républicain Laurin des
milliers de personnes ont manifesté à
travers le monde arabe contre l'État
hébreux et ses alliés notamment la
France jusqu'à alors on le rappelle
Autorité palestinienne et Israël se
renvoie mutuellement la responsabilité
du drame les répercussions de l'attentat
d' rass également la une et la
difficulté d'appliquer un plan Vig
pirate strict à l'école c'est le dossier
du télégram Oriane qui revient sur
l'incapacité de certains établissements
à mettre en œuvre toutes les mesures
imposées par le niveau le plus élevé du
plan Vig pirate contrôle visuel des sacs
stationnement aux abords des écoles les
délégués syndicaux breton qui témoignent
s'inquièent notamment sur les moyens car
je cite quand on a 1000 élèves à
accueillir entre 7h50 et 8h c'est tout
bonnement inapplicable autre inquiétude
il y est toujours au sujet d'arace ce
sont les fichers la situation
irrégulière du terroriste d'aras relance
le débat sur les expulsion systématique
des fichers étrangers et sur l'état de
la menace dans notre pays Midi Libre
fait un focus sur la situation en
Occitanie où vivent plusieurs centaines
de fichiers s le journal montpellierin
détaille les méthodes de surveillance de
ces individus et donne la parole à
François Xavier le préfet de l'éro 4e
département le plus confronté au
phénomène de radicalisation dans le
grand sud on passe à un autre sujet on
parle également immobilier ce matin oui
je voulais vous montrer ces deux unes la
première celle de la voie du Nord avec
son titre l'immobilier alcafar et la
seconde celle de la marseillaise qui met
en exerg un chiffre de la Fondation
abépierre 200000 personnes en attente de
logement sociau dans la seule région
PACA d'un côté la voie du Nord revient
sur les difficultés que rencontre
acheteur et vendeurs et de l'autre et
bien la réalité du mallogement la
pénurie du logement social et les
fractures sociales qui en découlent en 5
secondes Air France qui quitte Orly oui
la compagnie aérienne tricolore
regroupera excepté l'accord ses
opérations à roissi Charles de Gaulle et
c'est donc la fin de la navette Air
France avec ces 16 vols quotidiens entre
Paris et Toulouse merci Mathias merci
beaucoup merci Jean-Pierre sacoun
d'avoir été avec nous à distance merci
Marc Nobel d'être venu et merci Karina
zopardi on remontre vos deux livres ces
petits renoncements qui tuent et quand
la peur gouverne tout merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas H pour sens
public et nous on se retrouve
demain